So we're starting to see sort of a new divide
in the fight against coronavirus.
Earlier you had these metro areas with a larger
population densities, more flights directly
to China.
You started seeing those areas have more cases
pretty early.
So New York City certainly at the top of that
list.
Boston would be another example as well.
And you've got places that are less connected
to the global economy, having fewer cases
early on.
We are now starting to see a divergence where
the numbers are starting to improve pretty
dramatically in some of these early hotspots
in terms of a reduction in cases and a reduction
in deaths and a reduction in serious cases
in people in ICU use.
But we have a new wave of cases in places
that have been insisting all along, hey, I
don't know that we need to close.
We don't have any cases.
And very quickly, they are getting many, many
more cases and they still seem to not understand
how viral growth works.
Now, let's look at one example, and that's
Mississippi Republican Governor Tate Reeves
was insisting for weeks.
Mississippi can open we can open Mississippi.
Everything's great here.
And indeed, he decided to go ahead and open
businesses.
The cases spiked and he is canceling that
plan.
He's calling it a pause.
But OK.
I mean, eventually businesses will open.
The plan to open now has been canceled.
Friday, Mississippi had about 400 new cases
and 20 new deaths and they have changed their
plans.
Governor Tate Reeves should actually be applauded
for doing this.
We shouldn't make fun of the fact that his
initial plan was wrong.
He should be praised because he's actually
looking at the data and changing the plan.
Because when you look at other places that
have started to open and it's still in some
cases, we don't even see the full effect yet.
Places like Florida are quickly finding more
and more new
cases despite still having pretty low levels
of testing.
Virginia is now finding close to a thousand
new cases a day.
Texas is finding close to 1000 new cases a
day.
And they're only testing a third or a quarter
of what places like Massachusetts and Rhode
Island and New York are testing.
If you're only testing 14000 people a day
and you're finding 1000 new cases a day, those
numbers are going to go up even faster as
you start to test more.
Indiana is another place that supposedly had
no problem.
They were all set to go.
One of the top growth rates by percentage
now over the weekend, Ohio becoming a hotspot.
Georgia may be the hot spot by the end of
the week as Governor Kemp there has just blown
the doors wide open.
Georgia has nearly 30000 cases now.
I believe that if we had
stayed as close to fully shut down as possible,
just two more weeks everywhere, we would have
been in a good position to have more testing
by then and to be able to start easing restrictions
and guidelines.
But now a lot of these states are going to
fall very, very far.
Back here in Massachusetts, Republican Governor
Charlie Baker extended the stay at home order.
It was supposed to end today, May 4.
Charlie Baker has extended it by two weeks
to May 18th.
And we've seen cases level off.
We've got about a three percent new case rate
per day and it hasn't been climbing.
We've seen a net decrease in hospitalizations
over the last week.
Deaths have dropped from close to 200 a day
to about 100 a day.
Still a lot.
Still tragic, but that's the direction you
want to see things going.
My instinct is that in another 14 days, if
Massachusetts keeps doing this, the numbers
are going to look dramatically better.
The opposite seems to be happening in many
southern states.
Now, I want to praise Mississippi.
They had a plan.
We thought it was the wrong plan.
Many of us did.
They looked at
the data and they changed the plan.
We can focus on it was a bad plan to start
with and it was a bad plan to start with.
But lots of states have bad plans and many
of them aren't changing the plans.
As the data changes, Georgia, Texas and Florida
are examples.
At least Governor Tate Reeves realized the
plan doesn't match the data and we have to
change our plan.
Mississippi is a place with the worst health
care in the country, according to U.S. News,
50th out of 50.
They can't risk having their system overwhelmed,
which would lead to a very high death rate.
He changed his mind and that's great.
Let's see what happens in these other places
as cases spike.
Texas and Georgia, we will be following closely
all week.
Many states now also have armed protesters
demanding that they be reopened.
Protesters showing
up, yelling at cops, typically not wearing
facemasks.
Very, very ugly stuff.